جره اوكرانيا الى حرب استنزاف امر لن
يستطيع الغرب مواكبته التي تحدث عنها
بايدن لكن قمه رمشتاين بدايه العام اجبرت
روسيا على تعديل الخطه بل ورسمت جزءها
المفقود تسليح كييف لا يسمح باختراق
دفاعات الروسيه في العمق دبابات كياب دمرت
ووصول الامدادات الغربيه منها يحتاج
لاسابيع الا ان اوكرانيا تصر على ان
الهجوم الروسيه الشامل بدا منذ اسبوعين
بتعزيز القوات وليس بفتح جبهات جديده
ودللت على ذلك بان الهجمات الروسيه تضاعفت
واعداد الجنود ايضا
330 الفن مقابل
220 الف عنصر روسي بدايه العام هذا وموسكو
لم توظف بعد 200 الف جندي ممن تم تعبئتهم
جزئيا ما هي الخطه اذا فتح جبهه جديده من
بيلاروسيا بات مستبعدا الاوكرانيون
يناورون في دائره اصغر جغرافيا عكس الروس
وصول القوات الى بيلاروسيا شمالا او الى
اوديسا جنوبا يحتاج وقتا وهو ما لن يترك
مجالا للمفاجاه وعلى اثر ذلك قررت موسكو
تعديل الخطه هي الان تهدف لي منع اوكرانيا
من تشكيل احتياطات لبناء هجوم مضاد وقبل
ان يفتح جنود الاحتياط الروس جبهه جديده
باتجاه
الخركابوجيا قبل توافد المساعدات الغربيه
على الوحدات الاوكرانيه هل تنازلت موسكو
اذا عن العوده لقياد ربما خاصه وانها
ستكون اكثر كلفه من المره الاولى اوكرانيا
بنت العديد من التحصينات على طول الحدود
تعداد واعتاد الجيش الروسي لا يسمح
بالهجوم
[موسيقى]